mary kate and ashley olsen continue to
mourn the death of their on-screen dad
and close friend bob saggett
hi how you guys doing okay
even after all these years a source
tells et that they had a quote very
special bond we love each other and
we've been friends all these years
and we've been there for each other the
famously private actresses turned
fashion moguls attended the late actors
private memorial service on friday in
los angeles and e.t source says it was
an incredibly emotional day for them
noting that the 35 year old twins were
close with a comedian who made sure to
check in on them over the years
it's an extended family the truth is
we've always loved each other and that's
what i think made the show a success it
was in between the lines that stuff that
happens when it's real between people
quote they had a very special
relationship with bob and they adored
him
of course the olsons played michelle
tanner on full house the youngest
daughter of bob's character danny tanner
you just started jumping down to one of
those contests you need a whole formal
riding outfit it costs a lot of money i
don't mind
bob's memorial was attended by a number
of his full house co-stars including
john stamos dave coulier laurie lachlan
and candace cameron beret among others
kenneth cameron look she's my tv
daughter he's one of the most sensitive
people i know it really is family it's
been over 30 years that we've known each
other and e.t source says that although
the olsens grew apart from some of their
former full house castmates they always
remained in contact with bob who was
someone they trusted
bob was very protective of them and
texted them regularly over the years the
source adds that it was never a question
whether the twins would attend the
memorial and that while it was an
emotional day it was also a blessing to
be able to be surrounded by so many of
the comedians loved ones and share
memories and laughs in his honor
the source notes that the service was
quote very special and that all of bob's
favorite people were together in one
room
that's a love thing that's kind of what
it is bob was found unresponsive in a
hotel room in orlando florida and
pronounced dead on january 9th just
hours after he finished a stand-up show
outside of jacksonville he was 65 years
old
following the news of his death the
olsons honored their late tv dad in a
joint statement calling him quote the
most loving compassionate and generous
man
quote we are deeply saddened that he is
no longer with us but know that he will
continue to be by our side to guide us
as gracefully as he always has we are
thinking of his daughter's wife and
family and are sending our condolences
the thing that touches me the most
they're friends of mine
they are
really friends of mine it's a gift bob
continues to be mourned by friends and
fans alike including fellow comedian
gilbert gottfried who opened up to et
about bob's special bond with mary kate
and ashley he was like their father he
was very protective of the olsen twins
because
he
he knew them since they were babies
and he was with them every day for years
so
he he saw himself as their father so as
they got older they were going through
all their craziness and the paparazzi's
following them around he still felt a
sense of responsibility yeah he was he
was he cared about them
and gilbert reflected on bob's lasting
legacy
he'll be remembered for all the people
who watched him over the years yeah full
house and funniest videos the people who
knew him will remember him as you know a
great guy
really funny really quick if you had to
sum it up in one line what would it be
funny and lovable on screen and off
[Music]
you